to introduce our first Speaker Laura
Lewis from Caltech who will speak about
an improved machine learning algorithm
yeah thank you for the introduction
thank you to all the organizers for
inviting me to speak today
um yes I'm Laura I'll be talking about
an improved machine learning algorithm
for predicting crime State properties
and this is a joint work with Robert
Huang via trans Sebastian Leonard
Richard and John preskell
so first to give some motivation as you
all probably know Finding around States
is a very fundamental problem physics
and a lot of people care about really
solving this problem
however a classical computer still
struggle to solve this in general so
despite a lot of research going into
efficient classical algorithms to find
ground States or find properties of
ground suits there haven't been many
successes in finding an efficient one
that works in general all the time
is the central question of this work
which is can classical machine learning
efficiently predict ground States after
learning from some amount of training
data so this training data is
essentially some examples of the
algorithm is given beforehand and the
idea of machine learning then is does
being given this examples make the
problem easier somehow like being able
to just generalize from the examples
rather than solving it from scratch
so to go over
the uh the basics of classical machine
learning the goal is usually you want to
learn some unknown functions so I'll
denote this function as C and it just
maps from any input Space X to an output
space y
and in order to learn this function
you're given some amount of training
data so this training data usually comes
in pairs so the pairs here I label as XL
and yl where XL are just some inputs
sampled from a distribution D over the
input Space X
and the uils are the corresponding
outputs for this Excel so they're those
functions C that we want to learn
evaluated at this Excel and sometimes
this doesn't have to be exact it can
also be approximate
and the metric by which we evaluate how
well we've learned this unknown function
C is by this low average predictor so
here we have this this expectation
and it's evaluated over new samples of X
so we sample some new X that's not part
of the training data
and we sample it from the same
distribution D that the training data
was sampled from
and then we evaluate H star our
hypothesis function it's usually called
we evaluate that on X and see how far
away that was from what the actual
Target function C on X should have been
and so we want this low average
prediction error to be small
and the point of this is that we want to
do this with as little training data as
possible so this this capital N here
which is the number of pairs that we get
that should be very small and so this n
is called the sample complexity
so what about in our setting how does it
translate so in our setting we consider
some hamiltonian that's on n qubits and
it's geometrical and gapped and it can
be written as a sum of these interaction
terms so each of these h j are local
geometrically local terms and by
geometrically local here I mean local in
the sense they only act on few qubits
and geometrically local means that these
qubits also have to be nearby by some
distance metric so you can think of the
qubits on some some lattice and then use
a standard distance to say they're
they're nearby
and what we do in this work is we
parameterize H by some Vector X so X
here can take any value from negative
one to one it's an M dimensional vector
and I'll usually refer to this Vector as
the the parameter vectors or just the
parameters of the hamiltonian
so writing this parameterization we can
say oh just write h of X and have it as
a sum of each of these local terms HJ of
X so each of these local terms now
depends on this parameter vector
so what you can think of H of X is it's
just a map that takes this this vector
and Maps it to a matrix
okay so just a very simple example here
suppose we have X is just a
two-dimensional Vector so it just has
two entries X1 and X2
in each of these local terms one of them
is X1 Z1 and the other local term is X2
Z2 so something simple like that
okay so let's rewrite the setting up
here so we say that the hamiltonian
should be parameterized smoothly by this
Vector X
and throughout the rest of the talk I'll
use rho of X as the ground state of H of
x
throughout any time you see a row of X
it should be the ground state
and the goal here the target function
the C that I put on the previous
previous slides about machine learning
are these ground state properties and
the way I Define a ground state property
is Trace o row of X where again row of X
is this ground state of the hamiltonian
H of X and O is a sum of geometrically
local observables
um
I think I think we don't
really need I think we need just some
ground safe that we need to predict
properties of
any traditional schools
I think I think it might just be easier
yeah
I think I
um
but anyways we want to predict these
these ground State Properties where O is
a sum of commercial available syllables
and we have a spectrum are abounded by
one
and the training day that we're given
here is there's again XL and wild but
this time XL is sampled from some
distribution again D over this parameter
space
and yl approximates the ground state
property
I've just written that up again here
and so the overall goal again is that we
want to input this parameter to our
classical machine learning algorithm and
then it outputs some approximation of
our ground state property
another similar oh actually so the main
question then is can classical ml do
this efficiently so that's what I was
saying earlier about can classical ml
predict Grant State Properties after
learning from some amount of training
data
but there's a similar problem which is
yeah very related which is predicting
ground state representation yes
the training data is on on Facebook web
services oh it's actually going to
change yes yeah exactly yeah so that's
the key distinction between this when I
was going to say on the next slide so
here we have um yeah the more General
goal of predicting ground state
representations
so instead of given the yl which is for
yeah fixed observable this currency
property then say why L just
approximates the ground state so it's
just a classical Shadow representation
of the ground state
and if we're given this instead
essentially yeah the question then
becomes instead if we're given this
parameter these parameters we want to
feed it into our fossil ml algorithm and
then we output a classical
representation of the ground state
instead
and again the question then is can
classical ml do this efficiently and as
abanov was saying this is more this is
more General because then if we have a
ground state representation what we can
do is plug in like any observable and
predict ground State Properties
so we also care about this question
yeah so classical Shadow representation
would be so you would prepare like the
ground state
in the lab or something and then you
perform a bunch of randomized
measurements and you collect the results
this is polynomial size yeah it's like a
what he says
do you have actually a specific
realization in mind because if I pull
the material right for one shot I can't
really start relaxed for my distribution
so
you need a high degree of tune ability
yeah I think we do
we do yeah we expect like the number of
parameters should scale with like the
number of keywords I think but you have
a specific physical system in mind for
which this would be
um
um not like one in one in particular
just one that yeah it can be
parameterized
um like in the numerical experiments we
do use like the 2D random Heisenberg
model but it's not only for this uh this
model is just any so does any
hamiltonian
I suppose it helps that these and
arbitrary distribution so to the extent
that they are tunable you know you're
maybe a very secure distribution
is detector
can you we also love facilities like
homosexuals
but we're trying to deal with the yeah
most General possible
yeah and so the question of can Costco
mail do this efficiently was answered in
a previous work by Robert and
collaborators which shows that there
does indeed exist an efficient classical
machine learning algorithm so I denote
this as the G Star here that achieves
this low average production
there are a few things I'd like to point
out about this result which is first
notice the the training data size so it
scales this n to the order one over
Epsilon where n is the number of qubits
and Epsilon is this average prediction
error
but for a fixed constant Epsilon you
want the prediction error to be very
small then this polynomial really blows
up it gets really really big
and this isn't so great in practice so
in theory this is a polynomial so for
yeah theoretical computer scientists all
we really care about is that it's a
polynomial
but if we want to implement these
algorithms in practice to actually learn
these ground state properties and use
them then
this is very unfeasible so we'd have to
collect like a lot of training data in
order to actually run this algorithm
and that raises the central question of
this work which is can we do better than
this end to the order one over Epsilon
amount of training data
and there's another thing I wanted to
point out about this algorithm which is
this expectation here notice that the
parameters here are sampled from a
uniform distribution over the parameter
space
okay so they're not sampled from an
arbitrary distribution so this is
another limitation of this algorithm
and in this work we improve on both of
this but in order to do so we need a key
additional assumption so before the
previous work actually showed a sample
complexity lower bound so with just the
assumptions that I stated before just we
have some h of X that can be written as
a sum of local terms then
that polynomial that ends the order one
over Epsilon is the best that you can do
so we have to add this additional
assumption but it's a fairly natural one
and what it is is that h of X can be
written as again the sum of these h j
but now each of these
HJ only depend on a constant number of
parameters and that's what I'm denoting
as this Vector x sub J
okay so before HJ could depend on the
entire parameter Vector X at once like
all M parameters but here I'm only
saying that it has some more local
structure which is that each of these
local terms only depend on a few of them
at a time
this is really a key that I'll refer
back to many times
and so in this work we proved the
following rigorous guarantee which is
that there exists a classical machine
learning Model H star
that achieves this low average
prediction error when the trained data
sampled from any arbitrary distribution
so that's improvement over the uniform
case from before and moreover the
training data scales as log n times 2 to
the poly log 1 over Epsilon so when we
consider again a fixed constant Epsilon
then the scales is just logarithmically
an N whereas previously it was very high
degree polynomial so this is an
exponential improvement over the best
known algorithm for doing this
just any any distribution over them
yeah I think that this this is still
fine it's as long as um
that's my best child and imagine a
distribution which is only non-zero on a
single method
that means I don't need expectations
the issue the issue is that you're
training data and what you're tested on
is the same distribution
yeah and so again emphasizing this
exponential Improvement on the previous
algorithm when considering just the
scaling in terms of n but when you also
consider the scaling in terms of one
over Epsilon we have an improvement
there as well so before it was
exponential in one over Epsilon but now
we've improved this to only quasi
polynomial whatever
so we assume that the hamiltonian H of X
is parameterized
okay so this is our main theorem but we
also obtain a corollary uh just as the
second question that I stated about
learning ground state representations
so it's fairly simple it follows
directly from like the classical Shadow
formalism combined with the previous
theorem and all that says is just like
before if we're instead given the labels
yl as classical Shadow data sampled from
again any arbitrary distribution we can
learn a ground state representation
instead
that can predict
um well for any observable l so here I
guess by any observable oh I do mean
that has to be the sum of geometric
local observables with spectral Norm
bounded by one just as we assumed
but yeah I can do this for any
observable satisfying those conditions
using the same amount of training data
okay so this is again more powerful than
the previous theorem I just showed
because for the previous theorem then we
had to have a fixed o so we would have
to generate the training data only for
this one out then run the machine
learning algorithm and do this
and if we want to predict a different
ground state property corresponding to a
different observable oh we would have to
retrain the model regenerate all the
training data and everything
this is more powerful
status
yeah I guess that this uh you mean you
mean Square here yes yeah it's a fairly
natural like um
evaluation metric and machine learning
the most important
yeah I guess so yeah yeah this is more
standard in like missionary
naturally because it's actually
yeah because you can prove things and
it's very like standardly used
that is
yeah yeah I guess I meant like natural
in the sense the most released
okay yeah yeah
okay yeah and so we have this
preposition moreover this is basically
just a corollary from the previous work
but what it says is that assuming some
complexity theoretic assumptions namely
RP is not equal to NP which means no
randomized polynomial time algorithm
should be able to solve NP complete
problems
then for even just 2D hamiltonians no
randomized classical algorithm that
predicts even just one body observables
should be able to achieve an average
dictionary that's small
with polynomial time so although this
proposition is just saying is that this
problem for non-learning algorithms
should be very hard you shouldn't be
able to predict these ground State
Properties
this shows the power of the machine
learning algorithm which when we're
giving this training data it allows it
to overcome this
yes yeah so okay yeah so this is this is
a result about non-learning algorithms
excuse me
depends on the quality you need of your
samples
or any type of absolute precise noise
yeah so in in these results then
failure sentence I said it
here yeah that each of the yl's only
approximates this ground
state so
um this is up to like an additive that's
on here so we already have this and it
only gets better if it's exactly
but holding such Doesn't Have to
research at the bonds have to do but I
don't know yeah so it has
to be yeah
so does this have any implication on
solving NPR problems like if I have a
distribution which say in most cases are
pretty hard as well as certification of
them I saw it all of them
oh no no so this what this is saying is
that no randomized hospital algorithm
does not learned from data let's imagine
I mean a lot about that but the
implication if you use a machine right
so so I have a distribution which I
would say most instances are hard I
train it on a certain section of data
then I can solve all these this is using
that data so can I kind of compress the
tasks of solving natural problems
one of them
uh I guess so you still have to be given
like the the training data from solving
I mean I mean you know I'm not saying
I'm solving NPR problems efficiently but
I'm saying is that it's probably a
million that can solve a thousand of the
Dinosaurs most of them
that surprised
hardness is a worst case notion so you
can talk about average NP but then
that's not that's yeah but that's not
the biggest one
yeah but then but then also when once
you're in the learning setting you're
you're getting
you know you're being tested on the same
Distribution on which you saw answers so
it's a totally different setting it's
well studied I mean this this notion of
learning is well studied and it doesn't
hurt imagine you have a distribution
almost instances are hard right and then
this tells me I solve a certain faction
of them which is like
but then you know if you set up a
problem that way then there won't be a
learning algorithm
s distribution related to things like
easy Dimension or whatever
something called PC Dimension okay
big tapes usually
if you have a heart problem that might
be very big but that's something
okay what if I take I can I can take a
very large ad I go through the SAT
density right into phase transition
Point okay what we think it is I add a
little Epsilon error bar and I just take
my sample set from there right right
where the frustration free to frustrated
phase transition is
why can't I just generate my data set
from that so so so sorry this is very
dependent on the on the actual uh task
at hand so I think this is a big task
where you can do the learning
efficiently not all not all learning
tasks can be solved efficiently right so
so the fact that this one can is uh you
know every time you find a learning task
for whichever if it's an algorithm
that's a that's a moment to celebrate uh
for more from most tasks you know in the
situation that you described where where
there's no communication learning out
there
yeah
of your
s
I think this is
a classical spin glass yes
or is it one or higher right yeah that's
frustration this will be empty heart
right
this is
everything
and one that I kind of where I mean
there should be some kind of button
somewhere
but I I think this condition that that
you get to see random samples from the
same distribution that you'll be tested
on
different kind of uh than just just
being given an instance even if it's
around no I'm not saying this thoughts
and be problems efficiently just is that
you can reduce it but it will distilled
by quite a bit in the sense that you
know you only have to solve like one
percent of all the products and you
solve all of them
maybe it's
magnificent problems to this
I mean this is kind of the definition of
average cases like like if something is
like average you can reduce empty health
problems too
to like an average instance right and so
you only have to solve a small fraction
but this is not true of npe
right some of the questions
and then make make the solution
so so maybe no no but since since
um since you have strong intuition about
this you know at the end of the talk you
will you tell us
a good discussion
okay um yeah so this is pretty much the
setup and the main results so now I'll
talk about the ml algorithm in
particular and then I'll go over the the
proof ideas later and the some of the
numerical experiments
the key part of the machine learning
algorithm and really the the non-trivial
part is that some future mapping so we
take the input space and we map it to a
higher dimensional space called the
feature space and we do this with this
vector or sorry this mapping file
so I won't specify exactly what this
like M sub 5 is for now
um and it's not too important all that
matters is that it's much bigger than m
okay so we initially take these
parameters so this this represents again
our parameter Vector X
and what I said was the key additional
assumption here was that each local term
of the hamiltonian only depends on a
small constant subset of the whole
parameter vectors so only a few
parameters matter so let's highlight
each of these little regions of
parameters
and what we do in the feature mapping so
this is just a very high level sketch at
first
what we do is we take each of these
local regions and we
create a small Vector for each of those
regions so we're encoding this like
local structure of the hamiltonian into
the feature mapping
and then what we do is we concatenate
all these smaller vectors together to
form this one larger one and that is our
feature vector
okay so what is the actual details of
how we implement this
so first we write our observable o
corresponding to the ground state
property we want to predict in the poly
basis so I said that o was the sum of
geometric local observables and so we
can write each of those geometrically
local observables in terms of tallies
which of these policies here should only
be non-identity on a few nearby qubits
and what we do is for each poly we
Define some map Chi P of x
that says parameters in X that are far
away from P to zero
and by far away from P what I mean by
this is the following picture
so
she's a little hard to see but here we
have a
2D lattice I'm just considering for
Simplicity of our qubits and yeah this
part is a little hard to see but there
should be little lines between the the
qubits which indicate these local terms
of the hamiltonian so they're all just
two body nearest neighbor
and suppose we have some powley in this
decomposition that acts on only these
three qubits
and the way that we Define this like
Furnace from p is we consider some
neighborhood around this poly so just
within some sufficiently small
neighborhood so it includes this qubit
now
and we look at the local terms that act
on qubits only contained in this region
so namely these are these local terms I
labeled h14 19 20 and 25.
and what we do is each of those local
terms depends on some parameters so I'm
saying these as like the x14 X 19 20 and
25 here so those these are just the
parameters that each of these local
terms depend on
and what I'm saying by this is that
these are the only ones that matter only
within this region those parameters
should be the only ones that affect the
ground state property and so we set the
rest of them to zero
okay so that's what this map Chi P of X
does
this is kind of isolating each of these
local regions and saying that we can
consider each of them at a time for a
certain power
and then what we do is we discretize the
range of chi P of x
so by the range of chi P of X I just
mean the again the parameters but with
the parameter set to zero when they're
far from p
so we just provide this when we
discretize this then we just consider a
sufficiently fine lattice of points so
here we have each of these
each of these points
and all that we're doing is we draw a
box around each of these points
and for all the vectors in this box then
we map them all to their representative
lattice point
okay so for example in this box we're
mapping them all to X Prime
I'm going to call this box just some
some set of vectors as T and it's
depends on X Prime and P yeah
yeah so Kai P of X should
um I guess in general it should be for
mapping like n-dimensional like negative
one to one to the m
um to that same thing but then we're
just setting certain parameters to zero
within that
yeah so by the range I really just mean
like not all parameter vectors but
already we've set some to zero
yeah so this is a fairly standard
discretization and we consider this the
set of vectors that should be
represented by the lattice point x Prime
and it depends on P because we're doing
this for each poly
and what the feature mapping does then
is it just effectively Maps X to its
nearest lattice point
okay so here again we're considering
this local region and again because of
this map Chi P of X then we can just
consider one local region at a time
and when we consider that local region
we have this feature map or sorry we
have this feature vector
for that specific lap
and each entry in the feature Vector is
just a zero or a one
and namely it's a one if uh the X should
be in TX Prime
p
so each entry in this Vector corresponds
to a specific lattice point so specific
X Prime and we just put a one if
the feature mapping
um input X should map to that experiment
so when you set the parameters
um no we said so yeah so it's like
that's too special that's what I'm
asking about it was it just said H
depends on X in some way
s yeah I guess I guess the way
um I guess what's important about the
algorithm is that it doesn't depend on
how pages parameterized
okay
so sorry so you're kind of taking the
hamiltonian then you have a binary
variables and you put it in front of
each term and then you're sampling from
a distribution on that
okay
distribution like how is the
distribution that you're you know your
sampling from what's it look like
um
because
I could choose one which is support the
volume minus one
yeah this is the difference between like
where the training data is sampled from
and
uh like what we're doing okay
so this is the future about things so
it's just yeah a vector of zeros and
ones
and yes it's just a summary so first we
map again the parameter space to this
higher dimensional feature space using
this feature mapping that encodes the
locality of the hamiltonian
and then what we do is we just use some
fairly standard machine learning
techniques namely we're using this L1
regularized regression or the lasso
algorithm over the feature space so what
lasso does is it learned linear
functions so here this W Vector is just
a vector of coefficients and 5x to
remember is our future vector
so lasso is a fairly standard algorithm
in machine learning that learns linear
functions under the constraint that this
Vector of coefficients W must be have
one Norm bounded above by some B and
this B is a hyper parameter that we set
in the learning algorithm
yes yeah so that's actually a really
good point
um yeah so we assume that the ground
state or we don't we prove that the
ground state property can be
approximated by a linear function
yes
saying that it should approximate the
ground state property oh
yeah sorry okay that is very confusing
yes
yes yeah I should have used a different
letter for this that's a good
um yeah so this is the hypothesis
function that the machine learning
algorithm is output
yeah so in the proof one of the the key
step is showing that actually this
ground state property does approximate
uh is approximated by a linear function
so for the regular scan here you want
beam to be founded Along by constantly
it doesn't have to be bounded by
constant in fact the B that we have is
to the polylog one over Epsilon
yes yeah so this is something that
you've said because for these rigorous
guarantees um so yeah lasso is something
one of the machine learning algorithms
that we know has yeah very rigorous
guarantees on the sample complexity that
depend on how we set this fee so roughly
for our case actually very roughly
um here we have this prediction error
and one well-known result is that you
can bound it above by the training error
so this training error is how we did on
the the samples that were already given
and it's plus b squared so this is the
same B times the square root of log of
the the feature space Dimension over the
sample complexity
so it depends on yeah how large this
Feature Feature space is and also the
one arm production
so YouTube have non-constant dependence
on the parameters both these features
space scale it's going to show you that
um
so the key here
is some of it scales within
um and so that's how we get the login
again so the size of the future space
should have some scaling in terms of the
assistance side like little end I need
the number of qubits and so then when we
solve this to get a low prediction error
then this uh sample complexity we can
see has a lot of difference so it
doesn't depend on the constant like if
you move from constant to log
regime that we could have in effect
here
are you saying the parameters were
chosen between minus one and one yeah
it would make them a larger
scale them down
the only the only thing that matters
here is the
the number the number of parameters so
the Little M
because we mapped that to this
and supply
so I think we do assume is that the
number of parameters like this little M
that I had before is like order little n
so order on the order of the number
foreign
so that's what we use to get the sample
complexity
okay so again overall the idea of the
learning algorithm is again we're given
these parameters X and then we make our
future Vector we run lasso and then we
can predict ground State Properties
so now talk about the the ideas behind
the proof
so again just giving what we want to
prove so this is the the main theorem
and remember the the key is that we can
sample from any arbitrary distribution
as opposed to uniform like from before
and this exponential Improvement when
considering the scaling in terms of
system size
so before I remember this was this end
to the order one over Epsilon but here
we have this log n
and moreover something that maybe I
should have mentioned before is that
both of these algorithms require a
computational time that scales in little
n the number of qubits times capital and
the sample complexity
and so by obtaining this this
Improvement in the sample complexity we
automatically get a better computational
time as well
so just explicitly the best previous
algorithm had computational time and
Sample complexity that both scaled it's
very very large polynomials when
considering a constant prediction error
but our result shows that again for this
constant predictioner then our sample
complexity skills is only login and the
computational scale time scales is n log
n
ope sorry about this now
found on the storm and what is that
about yeah so the the um
the sum of geometric
that Michael first kill the empty heart
okay so the proofball
involved and the first part is showing
the the simpler form for a ground state
this is what I was talking about before
about the ground state property it can
actually be predicted or approximated by
linear function over the feature space
the particular W Prime here
and so the way that we show this is we
first show that Trace o row of X can be
approximated by some function f of x
which is the sum of a bunch of smooth
local functions and I'll talk more about
what those are specifically
and then we prove that each that this f
of x can be approximated by this linear
function over the feature space
and then by triangle inequality we just
get
a result
okay so how do we show this this is
really just comes back to the way that I
Define vector and
comes back to this picture so remember
what I was saying with this picture was
that all of the parameters outside of
this neighborhood of this poly p don't
matter and we set them all to zero and
so the key part of this proof is really
showing that this indeed doesn't matter
so showing that if we set every
parameter outside of this neighborhood
to zero then the ground state property
is not affected much by this
that's really the key idea underlying
this
so to formalize it a little more
we again write o in in the poly basis
and it suffices to show
you hear that Alpha P so this is the
poly coefficient here
times Trace P row of x is approximated
by some FP of X so this is exactly the
smooth local function that I was saying
f is the sum of
so we can see that it suffices to show
this just because if we sum on both
sides of Royal palies and this turns
into Trace o row of x and this right
side turns into f of x so f of x is
exactly the sum of these FP of x
and how is FP of X defined well it's
actually just the ground state property
that we want that we want to predict for
this specific polyp
but where the parameters for the ground
state are set to zero for if they're far
from p
so then what we want to show really just
comes down to a statement of yeah what I
was saying before about only the
parameters that are close to P affect
the ground state property so if we
change things outside they don't matter
and we set them to zero
so to prove this we use two main tools
one is the spectral flow formalism and
the other is lead Robinson bones
so this actual flow formalism gives an
expression for the directional
derivative of a ground state
and particular it gives a bound on the
directional derivative of the ground
state
and so what we do is we look at this
directional derivative in the direction
where we're changing parameters that are
far away from p
and so by this bound then we can show
this the change of the ground state when
we're changing the parameters far away
from p is very small
and so that's what we're using
yeah so what about again sorry to come
back to my dentist if I have a solution
which I can change continuously
because again friends you know I promise
that's not oh if I change has been far
away from switching to
each other
yeah so I guess but this um this doesn't
have much to do with the distribution
because we're not uh this isn't like
training data
this is just something like in the proof
this is saying like this yeah this
doesn't have much to do with the actual
learning algorithm it's just a result
saying that for this class of
hamiltonians that we're considering then
you can approximate the ground state
property by a linear function over the
future space
I'm hoping this question clarifies this
issue but the
are you assuming that there's a
adiabatic path between this original
hamiltonian and all the instances that
you're considering like uh
he just
um so different instances they can be
all Gap but they they may not have any
there may not be any like
pigabetic path between them yeah
yeah I forgot the distribution
minus one one m
as well
so if I understand correctly I think the
assumption is that the hamiltonian is
kept in the whole parameter domain is
right like the like whatever parameter
you including to the hamiltonian if the
parameter
you should get the hamiltonian so that
everything is continuously changing okay
so that's not realistic
sorry that's not realistic there will be
face competition
was actually that I'm intuitively
thinking about non-statistically
representative instances
and I I think that's the actual
confusion
most of what we're saying is not going
to be statistically representative so
most of the questions I believe that's
the issue
about the spectrophone here what are the
assumptions that you need
such that this works actually approach
here
we don't remember all of them
but we we saved them in like a
I forget what exactly it is but the
hamiltonians that we consider do with us
is
foreign
okay let me use yeah Spectrum full
formalism again just about in this
directional derivative and at some point
we come up with a bunch of integrals
that um need also leave Robin's
imbalance this is like a very
non-trivial part of the paper it's I
think it's like 30 pages in the appendix
or something um but yeah this is the
main intuition behind it
and the same theorem we just need to
show that each of these functions f of x
can be approximated by
some linear function over the feature
space
and what this really comes from is by
definition of the feature Vector so
remember the feature Vector was just a
vector of like indicator functions and
so all that we're doing is we're
approximating a smooth local function by
a sum of indicator functions and that's
something that that can be done so
remember this was
um how we Define the future mapping and
where each of the entries in the feature
Vector were just these an indicator
function over this set
so understand that this is very deep
Theory respectful formalism but I want
to understand roughly if you can give
some intuition about some locality
properties
the ground stage the
it applies to
um so in some sense basically basically
this this works for only in cases where
the ground states are not affected by
edge cases right but they're only
affected by small
by local properties
yeah that's true
I think roughly yeah I think it's safe
to say that
um yeah Special also could hold like for
the hamiltonians that were just the sum
of like these local terms um without our
like
new assumption about uh each local term
only depends on Social Clubs
sorry but we do know
did you just say that it's enough to to
restrict to local commentarians or or
yeah it's enough to say like uh yeah so
I guess what I was saying was uh it also
spectral flow and Libra Robinson bounds
and things were also applied for like
Robert's previous work
so it's not something that's like
um
it's not something that we can now apply
with the additional assumption we add
for our work
but yeah your understanding of when we
can apply first
I think I just wanted I just wanted to
clarify with the um yeah I guess what I
was saying was
like this this is not something
um that we need
like the um this HJ depends on the
constant number
that's what I wanted to just clarify
when I gave my answer
you want to understand what the
assumptions are of your objects here so
visit do you allow for a level so do you
understand Neighbors
well if you change a few of these
families that suddenly there will be an
exciting set of photographs and metal
Crossings or face conditions for
honest
I think it's still it's I think it still
works phase I think that's all that's
going on
that's all you're learning you can't
learn English
and make the distribution smaller it's
plausible
it may not be interesting from the phase
transition
s do you still make sense as a
Mathematica smaller magnetic fields
between yes
look the the counter samples are
statistically very non-likely right
so the statistical you know on the
distribution itself you're asking for
things that are very very unlikely
inside that distribution I believe this
is my understanding which we're kind of
settled together right
so
represents is very very rare inside your
distribution most of the things
I think what they're saying is that um
you would need like yeah you can predict
it for prostate Insurance that's that's
true
um yeah that's also something I was in
the previous word that's not something
that we get out of our additional
assumption it's not like it's beginning
um yeah but I think what
they found in like numerical experiments
is that even if you did try to produce a
frustration transitions it still works
fairly well it's just so we don't have
those
and why is it you don't have that
members guarantee is because of how the
distribution behaves
we need the gap
really global
yeah yeah we need like a gap phase
I mean spin glass will have a constant
account right
yeah sorry so what yeah it doesn't I
don't think it has to do with the like
the distribution here this is more of
something for a special flow which
doesn't have anything to it
yeah so this is the is there another
shirt at the end
um so remember the previous part really
just was using like approximation of
these smooth local functions
um yeah oh I guess actually something I
should point out about this is that we
in practice we don't actually have to
use these uh this feature mapping of
like indicator functions all that we
needed here was really that we're
approximating uh these smooth output
functions so for the numerical
experiments in fact we don't use this
one we use a Fourier feature which is
something that we don't have rigorous
guarantee on but we expect a similar one
will hold but the analysis will just be
like much more difficult
yeah the indicator functions are
something yeah not really used in
practice but give you a um
a nice rigorous guarantee
so the second part of the proof is this
Norm inequality
so as I was saying before the efficiency
of this L1 regularized regression or
lasso depends greatly on the L1 Norm of
the coefficient Vector W so remember
that
in lasso then we find some linear
hypothesis with respect to the
constraint that the one Norm of w is
bounded above by some B
so we need to choose this B
and the way we choose it is
um
important because if we choose this
regulation regularization hyper
parameter B such that the one Norm of w
Prime is founded above by B
then this will guarantee that whatever W
star was found by lasso this could vary
greatly from what w Prime was then
standard learning theory just gives us
that whatever W star is indeed found
will yield a small training error
so this is
how we choose B we choose B
such that the one Norm of w Prime is
bounded about by B and remember W Prime
was this specific Vector here
but in order to actually find what the
one Norm of w Prime W Prime is then we
need this following Norm inequality
so we need
um the observable oh remember that it
can be written in the Pali basis and it
will be written as a sum of geometric
local observables
and what we need is that the one Norm of
the poly coefficients can be bounded
above by a constant times the spectral
Norm of o this is one of the reasons why
we kind of wanted the spectral room o to
be bound above by one so then this is
absolutely awesome
and we expect that this this Norm
inequality could be used for you know
other learning theory tasks it's
something that's General it's not
specific to our our setting other than
that o can be written as a sum of
geometrical observables and oftentimes
in learning theory we do care a lot
about
the one Norm of things so we expect this
could be useful in other settings as
well
and so we need this in order to bound
the one Norm of w Primes
and the way we improve this Norm
inequality
is the following so we know that for any
Quantum State I call it Sigma here
that Trace o Sigma is bounded by the
spectral Norm fo
so then in order to prove this normal
inequality all that we need to do is
show that there exists some State Sigma
such that the one Norm of the poly
coefficients is bounded above by some
constant times trace of Sigma
so that's exactly what we do in this
proof it's a little bit of a complicated
construction so I won't show it here but
we do exactly construct this state Sigma
such as this inequality holds
and the final part of the proof is
really just putting everything together
so remember in the first part we showed
that there is a simpler form for the
ground state property that guarantees
the existence of some hypothesis
function that was the linear function
over the feature space
that has a low training error so this
linear function over the feature space
approximates our ground state property
well
and then using the norm inequality then
we can upper bound the one Norm of w
Prime
and in doing that then we'll get some B
that scales us to the polylog one over
Epsilon
and so then by the previous guarantee
that I showed for philosa which depended
on B and the size of the feature space
if we also bound above the size of the
feature space which is very similar to
the proof of this
um
then we just plug all these things in
into the standard learning theory of
bounds and we get a sample complexity up
around
okay so after the previous two parts of
the proof it really is kind of just a
plug and chug into the that here
okay so now I'll talk briefly about the
numerical experiments
so for the numerical experiments we
consider this model so it's a 2d random
Heisenberg model spins based on 2D
lattice
and we have this uh the sum here is
overall pairs of nearest neighbor qubits
and these jij are the coupling terms
so in this case the parameters that
describe the hamiltonian are just these
jij
well we want to predict like the ground
state properties we want to predict are
two body correlation functions so we
want to predict the expectation value of
this
and so what we do in the numerical
experiments is we actually use that
corollary so we use the corollary about
predicting ground state representations
instead of breaking ground States so
that way we can predict like many
different two body correlation functions
while only generating this classical
Shadow train data once instead of for
every single like two body correlation
function like regenerating it
so yeah here we're using the the
classical Shadow version so we learned
of ground state representation instead
and like I said before there's also the
adjustment about using random Fourier
features which are more robust in
general and more widely used in
Practical machine learning but we expect
the same rigorous guarantees to hold
and this is seen in numerical results so
here the gray lines are what was done in
the previous work so Robert at all's
work and the blue line is our new
algorithm
so here we see on the x-axis this is
training set size and on the y-axis the
average prediction error
and what we see is that as the training
set size increases we see a much steeper
drop in the average prediction error and
this indicates the favorable scaling in
terms of one over Epsilon
so what's important here is that we can
get um a lower or the same
um if we can get the same average
prediction error with a much smaller
training set size alternatively we could
get a much lower prediction error
um
as well as a lower with a more training
data
and also on the right here then we see a
nice visualization of the learning
algorithm so here this is predicting two
body correlation function between qubit
6 and 11.
and what we're
seeing here is how much really the
coupling parameter was weighed in the
machine learning algorithm like how much
it mattered in the final hypothesis
function
and we see that as we would kind of
expect so the thickness and the Darkness
of the line here indicates that it was
much more heavily weighted
and we see that between qubits 6 and 11
this parameter mattered the most which
is makes sense because we were
predicting two body correlation
functions for between qubit 6 and 11.
and we see that a small region of
parameters also kind of matters for the
ml algorithm
and everything outside really didn't
matter much at all
so this reflects our intuition about the
learning algorithm that it really does
leverage this like local structure
that
um the Improvement of the previous
algorithm basically uh
to give you a
samples but not in any actors are you
saying they supposed you're basically
saying this translates to the size of
the strings because uh
less less strength less samples will
give you the same accuracy and so
basically you're using the samples more
efficiently
it's a little bit of both so
um yeah so we get this favorable scaling
in terms of the number of samples but
the sample complexity of this algorithm
is like uh log n times 2 to the poly log
1 over Epsilon whereas for the previous
algorithm there was n to the order one
over so
the previous algorithm had this like
exponential scaling in the prediction
error the one over Epsilon so but then
here we have this quality polynomial why
is this I mean where where is
this we're scaling
yeah so it it goes kind of from this
and yeah so it's from this so remember
in the lasso guarantee then there was
this like B squared out front
um so so this is B
and then in in the lasso guaranteed
yeah but intuitively why would you
expect a better error I mean each drain
in itself each sample in itself
of course because you
you're looking at less parameters
so
I wouldn't expect the better behavior in
terms of the error it will just maybe
maybe it's just that you need this stuff
I don't know you don't understand
exactly
error yeah the sample better represents
um or I guess so so the algorithm better
makes use of each sample because it
leverages like this local structure
um and so it it kind of plays more into
yeah like the
other local structure of the Hamilton
here instead of before where there was
um
it was just like a general hamiltonian
and so it couldn't
use each sample as effectively
I guess it's kind of the intuition
how does a scaling from the theorem
compared to what you see that you're
medically expected
um I don't think we analyze in
particular like how
power reflector we just saw like the
general
the serum doesn't apply it would be
interesting to see if you still get the
same or even a better performance yeah I
guess but the the same yeah the same
essentially idea of the theorem
because the random array features all
that all that matters here is the
beginning of we can do like a warrior is
yeah so I think that's that's probably
why we just lifted
um General trend of it because also
we're pushing like some constant factors
and things in ethereum so comparing it
exactly is
so
um yeah so we we show that we have some
classical machine learning algorithm
that can predict ground State Properties
with much less training data than was
produced you know
and this raises the hope that you can
actually use these algorithms
practically so oftentimes when you run
like a an actual experiment you would
need to generate training data Yeah by
doing like preparing the ground state in
the lab and doing some measurements or
something or running like some
simulation algorithm like dmrg which
takes a lot of time and so in reality we
often can't generate a lot of training
data very well and so this yeah raises
the hope that we could actually use this
practically since we require less
training data
there's some open questions
um one is Ken Quantum machine learning
algorithms predict gravity properties
even better so we don't know if there
exists a Quantum Advantage for this task
yet
um another question is any are there any
rigorous guarantees for a neural network
based algorithms so there's been a lot
of work here in the references about
um about empirical evidence for and for
a good sample complexity scaling when
you're using neural networks and
especially because neural networks are
very popular these days in Practical
machine learning this is something that
you might hear about but no one's
managed to actually prove a rigorous
guarantee for this yet
and another question is can we predict
other physical properties so for example
like low energy excited suits
and another one is if we can generalize
this work for any observable O So before
I had it o had to be the sum of
geometrically local observables
um so could we get rid of that
assumption I think the main part where
we need it is with the the norm
inequality so I think that's
that's a part that I can identify where
we definitely needed this assumption
that o could be written as a sum of GM
actually local observables and we didn't
really know how to prove it
um for General o
yeah
[Applause]
okay thanks thanks very much
so it seems like the assumptions you
need for your your theorems or exactly
your assumptions
in which uh basically would work better
basically
I mean
you look at at least I can use these
things
so so are you sure that perturbation you
cannot even more efficient than what you
mean but because you would also get some
linear dependence on your kind of like
these small parameters
you can actually also talk about this
which is always expectation values in a
pretty efficient way if you have like
the if you know the the properties of
one
of one concept interface
so if you compare the resources needed
for this your machine learning
processors
um we didn't we didn't compare them
directly I haven't yeah I don't know
yeah I'm not sure about them
but don't you need more corporations
between different ideas
wow and it's not certainly not for those
or the presentation yeah but so you can
only do one order yeah but it feels like
she also
I'm
like there's no sense
or having access to this other
information
maybe the conditions again of the
theorem
yeah so this is this is the additional
assumption here that each of the HDA
depend on constant number of parameters
um they also have
um
but what is missing in this is
assumptions is that it all has to be the
same effect
I think it's implicit because it says
like yeah hamiltonian within all X in
the premiere
it says
for all of the x's in this minus one
common one to the end so there is a path
there is an idiomatic path
yeah I guess I think we don't need to
know this
right you don't need to but it exist
yeah but it does prevent it from moving
require that would not be probabilistic
right if it's the perturbation method
works well if it's got that you would
expect that information
but okay I don't know maybe you need
more information
a couple questions one on the next slide
when your assumption
sorry for the main theorem yeah
um H such a are you're assuming this is
these are geometrically local on
and
um on finite dimensional office
so doesn't this mean that every single
there's only ever have finite number of
parameters
because there's just a finite number of
Matrix elements for each local terms
we
don't want it to depend on like the
entire parameter Vector oh these Matrix
should not be a function of all of the
characters
another question on your numerical
examples this hamiltonian I mean yes
the Heisenberg interaction on the 2D
squared assets with
arbitrary coupling strengths is not only
q a hard it's actually Universal so
literally every phase of matter appears
in the phase diagram of this as you vary
the J supply chain and do you know that
the particular point you were predicting
around one-third right because uh you
look like these is this a gap I would
expect that this is small perturbations
around this where you're changing each
local coupling by small amount but
independently
that the this will drive it through
Facebook I mean this will be very
unstable the spectral Gap even if it's
gapped at this point
did you check whether it was
but I I think because so okay so I guess
like the point of the numerical
experiments to show even like with even
if it doesn't exactly satisfy some of
the assumptions of the theorem and it
still works very well in practice you
went up to five by five right uh yeah we
went up to
like nine by five
um everything's gapped for final
dimensions and I don't know how quickly
I mean this all of these hardness
results
who knows what the constant is
it is
no but no but this means that these this
for this hamiltonian it's it's like this
phase diagram is ridiculously
complicated
yes
I mean I mean this is right the outside
of the scope is a theorem indeed but not
only that at this point is Gap versus
that's a good point but also I think if
you perturb each of the local things
separately you will go through Facebook
really easily I mean every every
direction you'll have a phase transition
I think
so I'm wondering if this works on this
because it's just too small to see the
fact that this is really I mean the Gap
is it what's numerically what's the gap
so I think that's quite common in
machine learning that methods work
outside the scope to see reps right
that's minus that's good that's very
nice very surprising and I think that
this is
literally everything in physics is this
sort of typical do you know that uh
typically would be gaslights and uh
I don't know but it literally contains
every by this because this hamiltonian
is universal you can literally map every
Hamilton
whether it's fine-tuned or is it
difficult this comes down to the
question whether you think that
this goat like this comes down to like
what's the all qma problems how many of
them
are identities it might be that these
these skillful because it's not
difficult possibly but if you believe
the kind of like the stronger complexity
kind of assumptions about the sort of
the fact that
it's
when he can't be solved in public type
the resource standard measure stuff
which if you believe that simile qma
it's not that there's like one very uh
instances but like most of them are just
standard-ish complexity assumption from
the 90s then you would expect that the
gaps and gapless faces of this
simultaneous finite measure so what's
what's the standards a little bit neat
complexity assumption on qma though it's
usually classically but it's a fact that
there's a way of formalizing the fact
that you expect most empty right but
procurements at all
I don't remember
I mean I mean it's the conjecture none
of this is proven first
thing if um with measure one set of
instances of qma with solvable plugins
will not be very light or if you choose
this coefficient many instances I don't
know I think they might be even measure
a positive measurement well that type is
easy because this is a spin glass and
all of the I mean everything just looks
locally like a maximum mixtape
so yeah I mean are these is this easy
because for the typical instance of this
this is a spin glass the locally
everything looks extremely randomly
combinations
but this would make the local
observables easy to predict right
because it would be interesting to
compare it with a difference
you take a small cluster and you kind of
have the best and see what happens
I'm very surprised that this works at
this model
yeah so yeah like um in the previous
learning they also did this and I don't
think that um
I remember they they also said like even
if it doesn't have a case uh like in
within one phase then um yeah like the
point of the numerical experimences show
that even if like the exact assumptions
don't holds then like maybe we expect
them to or maybe they they will
um for a different reasons but the I
mean locally this is looking like you
know this is highly entangled since the
spin glass and
but you're looking
rights of the few body identity Matrix
is probably just um
correlations
the jnj that you chose here is plus one
minus one for uh
it'll be interesting to see this for
something like transverse icing where
all you're you're just looking at where
you know that there's a rather than
glass effects where you have an autism
disorder based through that
leave a comment below the questions
physicality
I mean I don't I'm not sure that the
information that comes from the
typicality of anti hardness
should go forward to the QA hardness
because obviously it should go forward
for NPR news but it could be that the
technicality of you know the hardness
the extra hardness of qma compared to
empty is not is not behaved in a similar
and that it needs to be fine too
to get the full q and importance I think
I think this is a very important
question in general again
really work hard
so
um
I think it might be good
[Laughter]
[Applause]